dwayne johnson and emily Blunt's Jungle
Cruise finally has a trailer wow that
scent is strong guys it's kind of a
weird morning for us
apparently there's a really nasty fire
about less than 10 miles away but John
and I are alive no rest for the wicked
even when the hills of the Greater Los
Angeles area are burning our friend
Sally lives not too far from us and she
just got evacuated we're gonna cover two
videos somebody should shouldn't be here
we're probably gonna be evacuated that
you know if there's anything but I don't
want to just go around and respond to
every comment so let's just shoot these
are only gonna be here probably for like
an hour and then we're gonna probably
have to go do some other things you know
once the powers that be give us the word
if they give us the word cuz you know
they're they they know it they're if you
are near that area please be safe
because I bet what you're doing right
now is watching this video
legend has it there was a tree in the
Amazon that possesses unparalleled
healing powers and that Arrowhead is the
key to unlocking it just wanted you to
know this has been disabled
[Music]
you should be outlets she's like Captain
Jack Rachel buy some wine in Amazon yeah
this one is undoubtedly the chief
[Music]
like the rides exactly like two of his
heads for one of yours
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that I'd have to carry you that's a lot
harder lady
[Music]
[Laughter]
the price just went out
[Music]
oh cool that look like a lot of fudge it
looks like a glass that reminds you of
like when the first Pirates of the
Caribbean movie came out which makes a
lot of sense actually given where the
smoke coming from I feel like that's a
Disney umbrella based on a ride yeah
well yeah yeah yeah and we're gonna have
to take this and I mean the Jungle
Cruise has even less of a story than
Pirates does so yeah we're gonna take
this and infuse it with some kind of
epic thrust of a journey and you know I
fill it with chemistry I found it
fascinating corporated that's the actual
ride yeah there's like not much that's I
mean you know that's super specific
about the ride other than the general
idea of cruising in jungles too the fact
that they brought in look at the
backside of water and the different
native people and stuff I thought was
actually you know I mean that's what
people are going to want and Here I am
satisfied that they did the Hat I mean
her character Rachel I wanna call Rachel
Weisz because I was like thinking of
Rachel Weisz from the first movie she
was in and then some of the antics she
was getting into seemed like something
out of a Jane Johnson uh you know he's
great at the comedy roles that her
jungle movie that he's doing yeah
welcome to the Jungle Cruise and welcome
to the Jungle Cruise indeed and then
their chemistry looks awesome too I
think is like d23 panel they were at or
something or they cannot presented
something you could see how great their
chemistry was already gonna be from
there watching just them in action here
it does have that parts of the Caribbean
vibe it has that you know watch buckling
yeah cool big production design
adventure it looks like the the rhythm
of it will be very fast-paced and
everything I missed that you know cuz
not even the Pirates of the Caribbean
movies have been able to capture that
kind of magic and this looks this looks
like it has some of that Disney magic to
it yeah it looks like it could capture
that magical epic quality because that's
something that pirates has that I think
the later sequels lost after part three
I mean say what you will about you know
two and three but they all feel very
large-scale
tangible very high production value epic
they're not covered in CG like it seems
like those early movies especially made
a lot of effort to put you in there and
this looks like it's gonna do that it
looks like it's also gonna have a fair
amount of CG but also at least in the
glimpses we got it makes sense yeah you
know given that it's gonna be like some
kind of river based action are we gonna
have to assist with CG to some degree
well at and then as it keeps going
you're gonna uncover more of the
mystical entanglements of it all which
is what which is what I'm most curious
about actually well I mean that's what
they end up having to build upon yeah I
adapt these rides yeah will this work
out here because the Jungle Cruise like
there's more potential in the sense that
there's less narrative than the pirates
ride has but there's also a weightless
narrative you know I guess that was
nothing that kind of surprised me was
how much mystical elements there is here
yeah I thought it might be a little bit
more on that and more like yeah
archaeological adventure or something
like that but then they seem to go
full-blown out but the designs of it
look really cool and the tone just like
the setting just the vibe of everything
like I'm yeah going back to this I don't
know exactly what the ear is but yeah
these old kind of Safari vibes and even
just the intro with now I want a code
rich is the intro watching her stumble
around and be charming but also kind of
kick a little ass and wear this like
chain reaction happened it looks like
there's gonna be a lot of fun energy to
just the character of the movie yeah
it's a really fun exciting adventure I
mean this is the director who did the
shall he do all the Liam Neeson movies
yeah run all night time stop in the
Commuter Orton apparently I think Dwayne
Johnson was really loved working with
this guy because he is in pre-production
to do black Adam right now it looks more
like it'll be Emily Blunt movie mm-hm no
this is setting a black Adam so what you
know what I mean yes she's deleted yeah
and he's gonna be the main supporting
like you know foil for her and then he's
top billing
cuz he's the biggest star in the
universe man yeah right or maybe because
he just has more star power well maybe
cuz man
I don't know maybe because he's the real
soon as Dwayne Johnson stars in it my
place 3 we'll talk about talk about what
I find interesting about it is for some
reason I heard Jungle Cruise and it
looks like they're gonna encounter a lot
of creatures and characters along the
way but the adventure is just them too
like it's not a big ensemble going on an
adventure together so all those people
on the boat either die or get off taking
them on a tour or something in the
beginning right no that's what was
taking them on a tour well John make
your jokes clear talk Philip says we
can't make Jeff we can't no I'm not all
right
that's what kind of surprised me was how
it's just them two unbloody a jury
yeah yeah I thought it might have been
like a bigger ensemble with them it's
just the two leads well yeah and you see
the teaser and you're like are they just
gonna be two tour guide so you like
getting lost you know adventure they
didn't bargain before but yeah like the
set up here is I think we need to get
out of here do you smell that that is
really strong it's like seeping really
hard to do yeah yeah guys we're gonna
evacuate you're gonna have wow that is
like oh my god that's so strong um you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell and are you
excited for chunker cruise leave a
comment below how's your respiratory
system that you thought it would be like
a we can make a joke about it in the
beginning but now it's getting way too
it no it's just like breathing in a
bonfire people look out for our
Charlie's Angels it's actually coming
out soon we're gonna upload it somewhere
else I would like to quickly give a
patron of the day shout out to a woman
named Jenna Randle Jenna you were
constantly telling me about how you want
to go on a lot more trips we have talked
about possibly going to Wisconsin
actually to meet up with a couple of
friends I know you live out there so
yeah be more than happy to meet up with
us the day we go out there I wanted to
say that with all the adventures you're
talking about once I saw that Jungle
Cruise shirt was coming out I knew
automatically you were the person I was
going to
shoutout for this because if anyone at
our patreon page deserves to go on a
cruise as much if anyone deserves to go
on a cruise it's you for the amount of
energy put in the world of wanting to
travel you go do it and I hope you
encounter bad guys along the way I hope
you get kidnapped for 10 years and then
you have to fight your way out of there
then you come back a warrior and you're
a little bit deranged and a psychopath
and then you kill your whole family and
all the loved ones in your entire life
yeah you know eventually they'll
novelize you and then you know still
make a movie about it you know you can
be your own sort of Rambo esque legend
just like pushed too far by the elements
so what does everything have to turn
into Rambo with you